[Musique]
le désert du sahara un des endroits les
plus arides au monde à 8000 km de là la
luxuriante amazonie un poumon de la
planète
tout semble les séparer
oh
pourtant ces deux écosystèmes sont
intimement liés leurs liens la plus
importante migration de poussière au
monde
pour la première fois il est possible de
visualiser et de quantifier ce panache
qui survole la terre autrement
invisibles à l'oeil nu
soulevée par les vents secs du sahara
182 millions de tonnes de poussière du
désert travers chaque année l'océan
atlantique
c'est la moitié des particules minérales
en suspension dans l'atmosphère
terrestre
de ce nombre 132 millions de tonnes
atteignent des amériques 28 millions de
tonnes se déposent dans le bassin
amazonien
[Musique]
le haut
les scientifiques de la nasa ont créé le
premier modèle numérique de ce périple
grâce aux mesures de calypso un
satellite franco américain lancé en 2006
sa spécialité la mesure des fines
particules des nuages et des aérosols
disséminés à toutes les strates de
l'atmosphère terrestre
une majeure partie de ces poussières
provient de la dépression du baudet
l'est une région au nord du tchad
réputé pour ses tempêtes de sable
il y à 6000 à la région était le site
d'agît gantès claque le meilleur tchad
aujourd'hui asséchée il a laissé
derrière lui des sédiments riches en
nutriments tout particulièrement en
phosphore
c'est un fertilisant nécessaires à la ji
mais il n'y en a une quantité limitée
dans la forêt amazonienne
il est lessivé par les ruissellements et
les eaux de pluie l'apport africain est
modeste en moyenne 23 grammes de
phosphore par ha par an mais il est
néanmoins vital
[Musique]
sans cette fertilisation transatlantique
les scientifiques estiment que les sols
en serait vidée en quelques siècles
voire quelques décennies